we have these misunderstoods these
things that have happened in our past
that we don't understand them and so
they block up I spent 90 minutes every
day talking to the same coach and he
would just be like what's on your mind
and so it basically would just clear
things so just clear items this is
something I'm concerned about or this
thing with my mom came out things that
were just draining my attention clearing
those things is really just a function
of understanding what they are they hold
attention basically and then once you
can release those you get the attention
back what are the things that are on my
mind right now what are the things that
are taking my attention and then what of
those things can I clear right and that
can be relationships with friends it can
be relationships with co-workers it can
be something someone said it can be
something that you felt as a response to
something you saw it can be any of those
things the biggest ones is understanding
what it is about it that bothers you and
then many times it's because you don't
even understand what it is and then it's
really just doing that work and diving
into it until you kind of like shed
light on it and you're like okay now I
understand this it no longer bothers me
I have my attention back